um so thanks everyone for joining us
today we're really excited to be here
and to share some of the odd data tales
that we've run into over the past few
years so I'll go ahead as we're learning
the platform thank you for your
patience okay so speaking today uh will
be Sophia Vargas Maria Cruz and myself
Amanda casari we're all on the same team
at
Google uh and for those who it helps you
can find the slides and speaker notes
for our uh talk today at B at bitly
that's
bit.ly
backd t a l s- py d a t a-g l o b
a-202 three and we'll share those out on
like uh LinkedIn and social media
channels that we're on
later um so as I said earlier sopia
Maria and I are all in the Google open
source programs office um Google's os's
mission is to bring all of the value of
Open Source to Google and all of the
resources of Google to open source um
our specific team in ASO is known as the
open-source contributor experience team
context uh that extra te at the end also
means we sometimes get to say the
context team like ATM machine which
everybody loves we're a group of folks
who collectively pull our experience and
skills in research data developer
relations Community Development
education user privacy and compliance to
improve the open source contributor and
maintainer experience and we frequently
get asked lots of questions about open
source that simply can't be answered
based on pure experience or without
in-depth analysis a few years ago we
specifically spun up
workstreams we specifically spun up
workst streams Focus solely on Research
to measure and model open source at the
ecosystem level as well as increasing
program L level data metrics and impact
tracking for our
team uh quite simply uh our team is
always looking for that magic spot of
any research which allows us to have
better data and better models so that we
can make better data informed decisions
uh really we just want to know where we
are uh so that we can work collectively
in and with our communities to figure
out where to go next uh like you uh we
didn't uh get here by magically knowing
what problems to solve having the
perfect data and always coming up with
the right answer as much as I would love
very much for the straightforward map
that you see here it simply doesn't
exist our team has a variety of
backgrounds interests and experience
that layer together to navigate this
space collaboratively and creatively and
today we would like to share some of
those foundational tales and projects
that shape our work and our view on how
to successfully integrate data centered
projects as part of a larger team and
vision so kicking us off first is Sophia
Vargas Sophia take it
away hello everyone as Amanda said my
name is Sophia Vargas next slide um I I
joined this team with a background in
market research Consulting analytics and
now as a program manager working on
research and analytical projects uh that
the center of all of these different
roles has always been data how to
collect it how to interpret it how to
explain it and use it effectively to
inform decision-making and so in direct
support of this team as well as in other
roles that I've had before next
slide in my role within the context and
Broad open source programs office a team
as well as in the chaos Community
externally I think a lot about
open-source health and project metrics
how we Define them how we collect them
how we portray them how we explain them
to stakeholders and particularly how we
use them to inform decision-making in
and around our project communities but
in order to do that we need to ensure
that we understand in fact what the data
is and is not and how we can interpret
what we see in the variety of metrics
that we collect next
slide and at the center of this problem
especially for open source communities
is understanding what it means for
humans for the people for our most
valuable resource inside our communities
many of these metrics around open source
projects are centered on people how many
contributors we have how many
maintainers we have what are the
activities that they're doing where are
things slowing up where are things
building down where do people need more
help but in order to try to generate
metrics that answer those questions we
have to associate activity with people
and assume that the things that we're
looking at are actually being done by
people so can we do that and to explore
that question next slide I'm goingon to
be looking at a bunch of GitHub logs um
GitHub is a popular platform for a lot
of Open Source projects to host their
code bases and interact with the various
contributor and user communities it is
not where all open source lives and it
does not capture all things that happen
around open source there are many
contribution activities that do not
happen on the gift so it is not a
comprehensive Source but it can be a
useful tool for those poost their
projects on GitHub um and as as such it
becomes a valuable resource for
open-source activity measurement and
metrics to explore a particular problem
um I'm going to be looking at data
collected by the GitHub archive project
started by a goog in 2011 this project
contains a comprehensive export of the
ithub event stream again dated back to
2011 um note that in the sort of
aggregate summary um I've put logged
events with star this is because this
project is not completely comprehensive
uh the number of activities logged has
been decreasing over time as the
platform has scaled and some of the logs
are being dropped so we know it's not a
perfect Source but because of the
historical Recs that we have it can be a
useful source to go dig in and
understand historical Trends and
behaviors
um for a sense of the pipeline that I've
been working with uh in this particular
sample we collected more than 1 million
events logged on GitHub in 2022 by more
than 20 million distinct actors note
that if you are looking at the octoverse
published by GitHub once a year um they
might quote number like 94 million
developers on GitHub um but these
numbers often include private
repositories in addition to public
repositories where in this particular
example we'll also be looking at public
repositories hosted on GitHub um so as
you can see on GitHub platform in
addition to things like code changes it
also collects issues and comments around
issues and comments around poll requests
and comments around changes um on the
tool so in addition to just code changes
you can have a little bit more
information around all the activity
happening around the code changes as
well as on the broader platform next
slide and when we think about that
question again of are you human for the
most part I'm thinking about automation
and known bot actors so to kind of bring
you an estimate of the
SC on GitHub or potentially in your
project um I ran Bas query trying to
identify actor logins that are like B so
it has somewhere in it so yes this is
overestimating the number of bots so
we've rounded down told you it's an
estimate but it's it's a starting point
um and through this basic method we
found more than 40,000 actors that could
be bought um representing about less
than 1% of all actors on the platform in
2022 so you might think okay maybe not
that huge of a deal uh
next but when we look at the impact of
these less than 1% of all actors they're
actually generating up to 24% of all
events logged on GitHub next and if we
look at the aggregate Behavior over time
we can see that this is only growing and
it's growing exponentially and if you
look at the bottom of this chart you see
push Trends and pull request events
which are the primary events triggered
around code changes and proposed code
changes so we're relying on platforms
like GitHub to understand who is
interacting with codebase and proposing
changes we realize that there could be a
lot of Bot activity happening in there
depending on our our project next slide
please so for an example how might bot
actors or automation impact your metrics
we're going to take an example of poll
requests poll requests again are a
popular thing to look around for metrics
who's opening polar requests who's
closing polar requests how quickly are
polar requests getting reviews closed
and merged and when we again consider
bot actors next um we estimate that bot
actors are also interacting with pull
request events in fact they are opening
and closing polar request um by looking
again at this query breakdown of the
actions involved around polar request EV
but when you think about what might be
happening in your own project remember
that this is looking at all of activity
across across this time frame and that
might not make sense each project
decides to use these various tools or
Automation in their own fashion and to
align to their own processes for example
next if you look at the kubernetes
project and here we're looking at the
kubernetes kubernetes repository within
the broader kubernetes project and we
run the same query to look at polar
class events generated by bot actors we
can see that there's are primarily just
Clos P requests they're not opening them
so if you think about metrics you might
be creating about pull requests and look
at these two different examples then we
have to choose how we either filter in
or out box actors and how that's going
to impact the met that we look at say
the number of open pull requests that
are being generated by people or closed
by Bots and depending again on what
you're measuring this can really change
the outcome so a reminder to acknowledge
how your organization or Community is
using automation and how that automation
might be being logged and collected in
your current metrics proces next
slide so again looking at pull request C
the broader GitHub ecosystem next just
to give you a sense of scale um we found
more than 70 million pull request events
attributed to bot actors which
represents more than 50% of all pull
request events on the platform so
there's a lot of this happening and it
could be happening in in your project
whether or not you recognize it and you
might think okay if I know who the the
bot actors are I know what their LS are
I can filter them in and out or I know
who the humans are I can filter them in
or out and this is a popular method that
is approached by by many projects
organizations and communities but can we
assume that activity coming from
human-based accounts is truly driven by
those humans I think maybe and if we
click in the next
build here we're looking at the top 20
actors by pull request events and you
can see that the top four are clearly
Bots depend a bot renovate Bots actions
the number five could be a person um I I
decided to redact these individual
logins to protect individuals privacies
but I couldn't confirm that these were
in fact Bots or people and so yes there
are a number of bots but there's also a
number of people and if you look at the
scale of activity that's happening
between the number four and the number
six it makes it highly unlikely that
that number five
is spending all of this time on their
keyboard generating these EV that's most
likely happening at the scale of a
script and anecdotally actually
recognized the name of this handle and
have interacted with this individual and
confirmed that they are in fact using
automation from a number of their
accounts on GitHub next
slide so in summary want to think about
how we me activity around our open
source projects I've been wrestling with
this problem specifically around how we
can can attribute work and Associate
work with individuals we want to give
people credit and recognize them for all
the time they spend on our projects but
also that all events logged are not
equal clearly they could be coming from
someone's four hour spent on their
keyboard or some script they wrote four
months ago so as a general reminder take
a look at how your organization or
Community is using automation what tools
are using what processes have you set up
and ensure that you have a way to
identify this with in your data or else
you're just going to have a lot of noise
and it's going to get increasingly
challenging to separate these two things
and that's the end of my data story so
I'm pass it on to Maria for the next
tale hi everybody I'm Maria next slide
please uh so I'm a program manager in
the Google open source programs office
and while I have mostly focused on
communication and Outreach in all of
those these r girls I have used data to
support my work including in my role as
a mom next slide
please um and I'm here to share my data
tale from the past specifically a job I
had 10 years ago in Buenos Iris next
slide um so back then I was the product
manager for a project to build an online
shopping experience for avar a boutique
grocery shop that had several
storefronts in the city of Buenos
Argentina avar as a brand was not the
looke per se but it had a sense of
quality Associated to its name uh you
were paying more but the quality was
worth it and also the experience of
buying there was worth it as well so the
online shopping experience was seen as a
luxury
accommodation it's also important to
remember that um this was 10 years ago
and only big chain supermarkets like
kood had online shopping available and
most people in sites didn't trust it
next
slide um so the agency that I worked for
that was leading this project was called
uplifted and it took care of web
development design and marketing we
built everything from the ground app
including product pictures like the one
you see on this slide um it was all
American experts living in monotis and
when they started to test the product
something wasn't quite clicking I joined
the project as a PM but my role could
also have been the Argentinian who's
going to help us figure out what is
missing in
Translation next
slide as it turns out the owner of avar
Mariano had a very specific Vision he
wanted to launch the online shopping
experience in Puerto Madero uh that was
a very that is a very exclusive
neighborhood in buono sidtis uh and this
was in order to build on H on this
concept of luxury associated with with
the brand or that he wanted associated
with the brand uh the issue was that the
only people the few people that lived in
Puerto moo fulltime at the time and the
majority of avar Shoppers in the
neighborhood were going there to work so
they were only interested in buying a
sandwich for lunch next slide so here
comes the data to make the product work
we needed to reach uh the Shoppers that
wanted to buy more products and spend
more money in avar as the PM for this
product I wanted to gather some data
that could illuminate our way
forward and so to produce this I created
a simple interview protocol to talk to
store managers across the city of
quoitis I created a sample I called 15
out of 40 stores in the city and I asked
them about shopping habits including
hours length of receipt and average
amount of money spent I summarized the
results and I told Withers the owner of
the agency that the best chances of this
new product succeeding was to try it in
palmo specific specifically in the Red
Cross that you see in the slide which is
the intersection of scalabrin ortis and
Nicaragua but I guess palmo didn't have
the same connotation as PTO Mero it's
Heap but it's not
luxurious um so this is how you lose her
uh by the way this is the title of a
book that I really like by junas a
Dominican American writer so as you can
guess already the online store was not
successful after all I think that if
there is one takeaway in this story
other than you should base your
Innovation planning on reliable data is
that if you're going to change things
for your users you have to make it
convenient for them and make make their
life easier and changing habit is really
hard but it we all do it for the right
reasons and with that I'm going to pass
it to Amanda who will share the final
data tale for this
session thanks
Maria
uh so hello I'm Amanda I'll also give
you a quick introduction uh for myself
um so I'm a pale white woman who wears
glasses I'm a researcher and engineer in
the Google open source programs office
um I'm also co-lead for project ocean
and across external faculty at the
Vermont complex system center um I do a
few other things I'm also a queer very
proud mama of two small humans a US Navy
veteran and I'm lucky enough to live in
Vermont in the United States uh so to
wrap up our Tales today I'm also going
to drop back into my first job as a
professional data scientist where I
worked at a consulting firm outside of
Seattle um and I worked on pretty much
any project they could squint at and say
yeah that that involves data you should
be involved in
this so at the time um everybody was
very excited about um data science and
big data and there were things like
sentiment analysis that were coming into
view that were going to solve all kinds
of problems and questions um and it was
interesting at the time that Consulting
wasn't really flagged for me as a way to
get into data science I think a lot of
folks at the time were working on
products or moving into some of the
bigger companies um but that wasn't how
I got involved I got involved as um what
is now known as full stack data science
where people would hand you a pile of
things to figure out and then you would
slowly pick it apart piece by piece and
then do all the steps for yourself so
the benefit of Consulting was that I
worked on a lot of different kinds of
Technology on a lot of different
problems and they were very interesting
problems um and Maria uh this goes back
to 2013 um and working with uh a global
brand to understand what people were
saying about their product um so I was
very excited to work with this brand and
understand some of the new technologies
that I hadn't worked with yet my
consulting company had a product inhouse
that they were using for largescale data
collection doing data analysis and
sentiment analysis um it was actually
fairly forward at the time for a lot of
the projects that were happening at
production at scale and it was fun to
build up those different skills so
working on this project uh with this
specific Global brand I was interested
to see also in the kind of things they
wanted to learn about I will say that
they did find things out and they were
surprised what they
found so the customer I worked with did
have the very real problem of quality
control and recalls so they had an
infant formula which they produced
distributed and it was consumed by a
global consumer base um this is a highly
regulated space they wanted to make sure
that they could explore that they could
uh try out a new signal um to track any
potential quality issues social media
the idea at the time was that social
media was the new emerging um space that
people were having all of their
conversations in and that this would be
a reliable way to do um alerting around
customer dissatisfaction so at the time
this did work for things like if there
was a flight delay some of the airlines
could start to see when people got
grumpy and then they talked and
complained about it on places that had
social media conversations um and so it
was seen as this new Collective way to
be able to gain and understand what was
happening with your customers and while
that was true for things like flight
delays uh at the time it was not exactly
the thing that you wanted to be using
for this specific use case so that was
our problem number one the hypothesis
was that we would get an early signal
for a recall um for the product that
impacted highly vulnerable populations
and it would be one more marker to help
them understand that they needed to
initiate a recall across formula um now
Big Data like I said big data sentiment
analysis honestly would land you just
about any product marketing contract in
2013 because people wanted it to solve
all the problems that they had and this
is where I first learned as a data
scientist about the concept of solution
mismatch so at the time uh in 2013 both
social media and sentiment analysis and
production pipelines were honestly not
far enough evolved for alerting and that
wasn't the problem of the platforms
themselves it was just not necessarily
one the reliable sense for that it was
also not what was being um it was going
to solve that
problem uh the second part of that is um
why it wasn't going to solve that
problem so uh this is a classic data
analysis Challenge and that's even just
finding what you want from the volumes
that you don't so the analysis in The
Proposal was honestly just flawed from
the beginning when people have an
emergency impacting their child they
don't go to social media to complain
about it they go to emergency services
so that early signal that this company
was looking for was not going to show up
in these places until either like well
after the fact that something happened
which is what happens more now um but at
the time people weren't even using it
for that purpose so they were looking
for social media to surface these
conversations around when they should
pay attention to a specific region or a
specific um group but that wasn't what
they were able to find it was not the
main topic of what was being talked
about when you talked about infant
formula in 2013 on social media so what
did people talk about when they talked
about infant formula in social media in
well they talk about what a lot of
people talk about now when they talk
about babies online so chances are when
you're online talking about babies um
and usually now this infant formul brand
they're probably talking about poop so
our clients learned that their consumers
compared their product more to what was
happening with their end users than they
did that they needed to Signal a recall
they learned their brand perception
about their Global product was most
strongly associated with poop uh this
came up very negative in our sentiment
analysis because at the time the
embeddings and methods that we were
using strongly Associated anything to do
with poop in the negative sense so they
also always got a very strong signal
that their brand had a negative
perception when it was honestly just a
lot of parents talking about their kids
and the things that they normally talk
about when they get together and you
have this new human that you're looking
at who creates things that you're trying
to figure out so it wasn't it wasn't
anything that was truly negative it was
just a normal social pattern that was
happening in a social space but it
wasn't what they were looking for and it
wasn't getting them closer to what they
wanted to
understand so how does this translate
towards data scientists new data
scientist Lessons Learned there were a
few things I learned from that project
that really have been very valuable for
me for every data center project moving
forward the first is that just because
your client asks for something it's not
necessarily what they want or need so
really identifying the problem they are
trying to solve and what they want to
have and what success looks like at the
end is super important for moving them
forward regardless of the data that
you're working with and part of your job
is to be able to say after you've done
some work I hear that's what you want
you're not going to get there this way
and here's why so not just telling them
why things are not working well or why
the data is not taking them where they
want to go but offering up either
Alternatives or different paths forward
so they can get to where they want to go
or telling them this isn't just going to
work in the time frame and the way that
you allow um also because it's an
available data Source it doesn't make it
the right data source so just because
something is a group of data that is
easy for you to pick up that doesn't
mean it's also going to be the right
information that's going to lead you to
the place you want it to be I think
Maria found out some really interesting
things around trying to get to the the
way that her customer wanted to be
working but also they didn't like that
outcome either Sophia talked about that
as well as the here's the thing you may
want to be measuring but sorting it out
is going to give you a bucket of things
that are also really hard and maybe not
true um and finally uh when it is the
main centroid when it's the main topic
that's happening it's no longer an edge
case so just because you want it to be
the thing that people are not having
conversations about that doesn't mean
that's what they're going to be talking
about um and so we want to make sure
we're wrapping this up and leaving time
for questions um we just want to really
encourage everyone here to keep asking
yourself and each other hard questions
about how you design problems what data
you collect the conclusions you draw
from those because these are large
ecosystems right data is actually a
representation of people technology and
ideas and it's all fairly messy but
we're all here together and we're all
here to work together and help each
other out so thank you very much and we
will stay online for four more questions
if you have any questions please put
them in the Q&A or the chat and we are
helpful happy to answer
them and thank you for the
claps
oh you're welcome Luka thank you very
much for
coming oh we had one pop up um so
someone just asked when it comes to
presenting Alternatives is there
strategy you tend to follow because
sometimes it's hard to convince people
even when the data is there uh Maria
would you like to start with that or
would you like or
Sophia um I I can take a stab at this I
don't I don't think I have the response
because uh yeah it's not always
sucessful but I I think data just
presenting the data and pres presenting
your reasoning behind it and why you
think you should listen to
that is what has worked with me when for
me when when I had to do that in the
past it doesn't always work because
sometimes people are really attached to
an idea but usually presenting your
reasoning and allowing other people to
see your thinking process is is
Good
Sophia um yeah I would I would plus one
that I feel like it's all about the
story um know what generally needs a
story around it and is the present
who sharing data I think you have an
opportunity to to get people to see how
you see
itting it but if you have a strong story
that as mentioned is informed through
solid reasoning and a logical
progression hopefully you could convince
them otherwise but I do think that is a
a generally a hard problem
Manda yeah I think um I think it
definitely comes down to understanding
what is the um we have a conversation a
lot in our team about outcomes versus
outputs and a lot of metrics are really
measuring outputs but really you need to
get to the next step to understand the
outcome so I feel like that can be that
can be Associated emotionally where
someone has a specific outcome that
they're emotionally tied to like the
concept of luxury and making sure that
that's the association it can also be
they have a very specific outcome that
they're associate with around things
like um economic modeling that they're
doing as a part of their business so I
think it's making sure you're aligning
and understanding like where the
friction is coming from on why they
don't want to Pivot to a new kind of
strategy or alternative what are those
barriers they're presenting as a part of
that and is there an emotional component
or is there a is that tied into
something else that's the outcome that
they're driving towards um I think we
have time for exactly one
more
um I I'm I'm going to go actually
quickly to um to uh Han Kim so there was
a question of is there analysis of the
open project activity available online
and other sources available for this
type of
information I'll take that one um and
I'd say there's many um they're not all
reliable sources but I like to start
with where all of the activities
happening around your project but
acknowledging that there's going to be a
lot of gaps in that information so if
you want to do something truly
comprehensive you're probably also going
to P it with going out and talking to
people and running surveys and trying to
fill the holes for individuals
experiences as well as how their
behavior is reflected inside a
data discourse or stack Overflow or all
these other places that your community
is active um Amanda I know you've worked
a lot with this as well I want to pass
it to
you yeah I think um our team tends to
share our work as well on open source.
gooogle which we share in the beginning
and we do some reports on there so if
you're interested in following along
with that you can find that as well from
there and I'm really sorry I have to we
have to go because we have to let the
next session start so thank you everyone
who joined us today please don't
hesitate to reach out um we'd love to
chat with you more and we'll try to
catch up with you on Discord if we
didn't catch you today thank
you